[Music]
on this monday night a new wave of covid
19 and the same old problems
the crisis looming in long-term care
homes it seems like a band-aid solution
the new help being brought in and the
questions about qualifications
the dispute with no resolution in sight
we cannot as a government
tell first nations what a moderate
livelihood is demands to better protect
indigenous fishers good luck getting a
flu shot why some canadians will have to
wait
to roll up their sleeves and switching
political parties i can't possibly
in good conscience support this type of
president
for republicans swearing off donald
trump
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what is happening in
long-term care homes in parts of this
country
community spread of kobit 19 is
beginning to seep into care homes again
british columbia reported four new
outbreaks in long-term care homes over
the weekend
there are now almost 20 long-term care
assisted living and acute care
facilities without breaks in that
province
in ontario 86 long-term care facilities
now have outbreaks and more than
1900 residents have died in that
province
nationally about 80 percent of covid 19
related deaths have been in long-term
care
hiring and retaining enough staff to
work in them remains a huge issue
as mike relay reports the solutions
being looked at
are nothing more than band-aids the
first wave of covet 19
put a wall between maureen mcdermott and
her mother i can't tell you what it was
like
to visit my mother outside of a window
with copd dimension alzheimer's at
93 and getting covered miraculously she
survived
but when her long-term care home opened
its doors in july
the figurative wall between mother and
daughter remained
she no longer remembered maureen who is
now
fearful and anxious of a second wave
it's like a ptsd
that's just creeping up that we're gonna
have to go through this again
so these plans need to be in place
with no questions except there's a lot
of those
donna duncan the director of the ontario
long-term care association
told an independent commission she
expected solutions over the summer
are we ready we're concerned that we're
not she added that staffing remains a
critical issue
with lower pay and benefits than
hospital workers who do the same job
long-term care homes have had problems
retaining
much less hiring new staff you know
calling them heroes on the front line or
throwing them a couple extra bucks here
or there for a few months
that's temporary we need a solid
permanent solution in the spring prime
minister justin trudeau sent in the
military to the hardest hit facilities
for the second wave he's announced
funding for the red cross to hire staff
to help personal support workers with
the basics such as
socializing with seniors feeding them
and making sure they're safe
and as to the qualifications needed to
apply for the job
it comes down to you have to like
seniors and pass a police check
standards industry insiders say would
have been unthinkable pre-pandemic
because if you're trying to move
somebody and they're a two-person lift
and there's nobody else to help you
you're gonna grab somebody who's
available and that's gonna be an
untrained worker and that's unsafe for
both the worker as well as the resident
the job postings have been up for just
over a week the red cross declined to
say how many canadians have applied
well i think we've learned something the
question is have we provided any
solutions and i think those are two
different questions
mike drolight global news toronto the
outbreak at a spinco studio in hamilton
ontario has turned into a cautionary
tale of exponential spread
the city of hamilton has created a
graphic showing how what started as one
infection has led to at least 74 cases
of covid19 in the community
the graphics shows that one kate that
one case led to 48 infections at the
spin co studio in downtown hamilton and
then spread
more widely infecting people in 15
households eight schools and child care
centers
six health care facilities and 22 other
workplaces
hamilton's medical officer of health
says that happened even though the spin
studio and its patrons followed
all public health guidelines for fitness
studios the province is now
reviewing those guidelines in quebec
frustrated health care workers disrupted
traffic on two bridges today
demanding better working conditions
nurses and other health care workers
briefly blocked traffic on the quebec
bridge in quebec city and on
the jacques cartier bridge in montreal
union representatives say the pandemic
is putting a strain on the health care
system
and say workers deserve more stable
schedules improved nurse to patient
ratios
and more full-time positions quebec
reported more than one thousand new
cases of covid19
today at the same time we are moving
into flu
season and we've all heard the message
that it's more important than ever to
get your flu shot this year so hospitals
aren't overrun with both flu
and covid19 patients flu shots are now
available across most of the country
appointment only clinics opened in
alberta and saskatchewan today
the plan is to distribute a record
amount of flu vaccine without having
mass vaccination clinics as heather urex
west explains that means
long waiting lists in some places
alhendri gets a flu shot every year but
this year facing the double threat of
flu
and kovit 19 henry made sure he was
among the first in line
just decided we wanted to sign up and
get it done early a lot of regulars
but we've had a lot of people come in
that don't usually get their flu
vaccination so
i think there's more people more
interested this year for sure pharmacies
like this one have been busy in recent
days helping to meet what's expected to
be record demand for the flu vaccine
without the usual clinics operated by
public health usually a spike in demand
for vaccine results in
long lineups and crowded clinics but
under kovit 19 protocols
each appointment takes more time every
injection that we do
every flu shot that we do takes about 10
minutes in total chu
says the staggered appointments are
necessary to cut down on the number of
people in the pharmacy at one time
but it means available openings are
filling up fast
so what's happening right now is that up
to two weeks from today's date it's all
booked up
but we will be opening up more spots as
the vaccines keep on coming in and we do
get confirmation that it is coming in
the falls flu shot rollout is being seen
by many as a chance to practice for a
possible
coven 19 vaccine rollout in kelowna b.c
one doctor's office offered the shot at
a drive-through clinic
while the saskatchewan health authority
is making the vaccine available
in as many locations as it can in
approaching this with an
all hands on deck approach where every
healthcare encounter is an
opportunity to be immunized for
influenza
we can trial a new way
to to do things to see what works
and what doesn't ahead of what everyone
hopes will be
another vaccine rollout very soon
heather urex west global news
calgary canada has now surpassed more
than 200 thousand cases of covet 19.
british columbia reported a new high
today 174
new positive tests manitoba had 80 new
cases of covet 19
today and new restrictions are going
into effect there in winnipeg and
several surrounding communities
gatherings are now limited
to a maximum of five people bars
entertainment facilities and casinos are
closed
for two weeks in ontario 704 new cases
were reported today and the provincial
government recommended against
trick-or-treating in the covid19 hot
zones that includes york region which is
now in stage two of that province's
pandemic protocol
it means gyms movie theaters and casinos
are closed and indoor dining at
restaurants is banned
the new rules will be in place for 28
days
and the canada u.s border will stay
closed until at least november 21st
the land border travel restrictions were
extended again today
the border has been shut down to all
non-essential travel
since march just over two weeks to go
until the u.s presidential election and
americans are already voting in record
numbers
nearly 30 million people have cast
ballots in early voting
often lining up for hours at polling
stations which were
not prepared to handle all the people it
could point to a record turnout this
election
and as jackson proskow reports there are
some theories about
what all this early voting could mean
in greenville north carolina they're not
waiting for november 3rd
i want to get it over with it early for
the crowd get here
it's the same story in florida where
huge lines met the first day of early
voting
and where 18 percent of voters have
already returned their mail-in ballots
this is a lifetime election this is
a very important election millions of
americans have decided it's better to
vote now
standing in line for four hours or more
in some cities
instead of waiting for an uncertain
election day i think a lot of people
don't want to wait to the last minute
the pandemic fears of voter intimidation
and president donald trump's baseless
claims about the vote
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen have driven
record-shattering early turnout across
the country 10 times higher than in
2016.
the first thing we're seeing in early
voting is just massive turnout
record-breaking turnout we've seen
turnout approaching 30 million votes at
this point
nearly one million north carolinians
voted in person
in just the first four days of early
voting many
driven by fears that mail in ballots
will be disqualified
i think it's very important that you do
go vote in person instead of
mailing your ballot that way you know
your vote is cast and know
that there's no way to rig that type of
election who's turning out early so far
more democrats than republicans
more women than men that may not last
a lot of republicans have clearly
listened to the president
and it appears they're holding off until
election day to cast their ballot
that does call a lot of this into
question in terms of where it ends up
that is the great unknown uncertainty is
driving early voter turnout
this just seemed like the most
guaranteed way it's also making it
unusually tough for either side to know
how the election will unfold
all donald trump and joe biden can do is
convince their supporters to vote
no matter when where or how they do it
jackson prosko global news greenville
north carolina
now to the dispute over the lobster
fishery in nova scotia
after days of demanding federal
intervention federal cabinet ministers
turned their attention today to the
escalating violence against indigenous
fishers
the acts of violence we have seen in the
past days
and weeks are disgusting unacceptable
and racist in nature the federal public
safety minister has called in rcmp
reinforcements from other provinces
but after a weekend of violence
including the torching of a migma
lobster fishing compound it's not at all
clear that sending in more police will
resolve
what's at the heart of the conflict
abigail beeman reports
early this morning in southwest nova
scotia a protest by commercial fishers
outside a federal government office
they say they've been reporting growing
tensions for years with no
action we've been shut out by the
federal government
ottawa says it's listening to the
concerns and lobster conservation is
crucial
the indigenous fisheries industry is an
infinitely small portion of the
commercial fisheries
uh again it's very important for people
to get that create a precedent
of fishing outside of the season and
then enabling
uh many more fishermen and traps in the
water in 5
10 20 years from now then i mean you
might have
a serious issue with conservation part
of the issue there's no definition for
moderate livelihood indigenous fishers
were granted the right to fish for one
in a 1999 supreme court decision
the fisheries minister says she won't
negotiate in public
we cannot as a government tell first
nations what
a moderate livelihood is that is up to
them to work with us to define
while the public safety minister says
more police are on the ground in nova
scotia available for land and
water after this massive lobster pound
fire that left a person of interest in
hospital with serious injuries
the sabbath first nation chief says it's
not enough he says indigenous fishers
are unprotected on the water facing
vandalism
dfo needs to come in there's been no
presence there at all you know they send
one coast guard boat on the water
but that coast guard boat's been there
when when everything else went down it's
just like the police officers standing
there they're just standing by
there is a need for for
significant reform and in respect to how
police
perform their services in indigenous
communities but the public safety
minister stopped short of his indigenous
services minister
colleague who said monday indigenous
people have been let down by the police
who are sworn to protect them abigail
beeman global news
ottawa we have an in-depth look at
what's led to the lobster fishery
dispute in nova scotia that's on our
website global news dot ca slash
global national some americans are
making it clear how they'll vote
coming up the republicans who were
refusing to support trump
plus how to have fun at a concert in the
time of covid19
it's been just over six months since the
global number of coved 19 cases hit 1
million
today that number is 40 times higher
according to johns hopkins university
the world surpassed 40 million confirmed
cases today
as many countries face a second wave
three countries the u.s
india and brazil account for more than
half of the infections
in the world a surge in cases in europe
is forcing some countries to reimpose
lockdown measures in belgium the
government warns
shutdowns are needed to prevent what it
calls a tsunami of infections
restaurants and bars have closed in
belgium and will stay that way for four
weeks
the government is also restricting
alcohol sales and imposing limits on
social interactions
belgium's health minister says he fears
the country could get to the point where
he says it can no longer control what's
happening
and sweden which resisted imposing
restrictions in the early months of the
pandemic is now planning localized
restrictions
there's been a steady rise in covet 19
cases there over the past six weeks
sweden's public health agency is working
with regional authorities that
as of today can enforce restrictions
such as reduced hours at restaurants
sweden is the only scandinavian country
to surpass 100
000 cases and its death rate per capita
is among the highest
in the world and though covid19 is still
a big problem in brazil
some people are enjoying live music
there again with
safety protocols in place
[Music]
this outdoor concert in rio de janeiro
set up physically distanced
dance boxes for groups of six people
brazil has reported over
5.2 million covid19 infections
still ahead she's demanding democracy
for belarus but she's in exile we hear
from the woman who many feel should be
leading the country
tens of thousands of people in belarus
are refusing to give up they're still
taking to the streets of the capitol
demanding alexander lugashinka step down
it is widely accepted he lost august's
election to opposition leader svetlana
tikanovskiya
many governments including canada's call
that election fraudulent
ticonosuquia is now living in exile in
lithuania with her two children
our redmond shannon spoke to her about
the challenges she faces
and the important role she says canada
is playing in the struggle
another weekend another huge
demonstration in belarus
tens of thousands marched despite a
threat police would use firearms
again calling for president alexander
lukashenka to step down
we have to decide everything by
ourselves the woman they believe
won august's election remains in exile
in neighboring lithuania
i would be more useful here and safe
than in jail in berlin because i'm sure
that
as only i passed the border i will be
jailed svetlana tikkanovskiya only
entered the campaign
after her husband and opposition
activist was jailed in may
she finally spoke to him on the phone
just a week ago
he was upset because he asked how his
children and they told him that our
younger daughter she is crying
every evening where is my daddy
and she's only five but she i think she
realizes that it's too
long that he's absent sikanovskiya leads
a group of mostly
female opposition activists all jailed
or
in exile now in belarus everybody is
fighting
women old people people with special
needs
you know everybody is against this
regime tikinovsky has demanded that
police violence
ends the political prisoners are freed
and that lukashenka resigned by sunday
otherwise she says there will be a huge
nationwide strike
the next day on friday canadian foreign
minister francois philippe champagne and
tikkanovskiya resisted an urge to hug
she says he was the first foreign
politician to call her in exile
he was so just talking to me like a
friend
i was so unexperienced i didn't know
what to talk about with
foreign leaders but he was so kind he
was so supportive
svetlana tiganovskiya has had to learn
leadership
fast she says mediation talks are now
key and insists russia which supports
lokashenka
must be at the table redmond shannon
global news london
getting off the trump train next the
republicans rallying against the
president
president donald trump certainly has an
enthusiastic base of supporters
but there are some republicans who are
fed up with his rhetoric and say
they will vote democrat for the first
time in their lives
some have formed groups trying to get
more republicans to vote for joe biden
mike armstrong spoke with one lifelong
republican who says
he didn't leave the party the party left
him
you would like to be voting republican
you know
i would love to be voting republican
because it's not easy to go against the
party you've supported your entire life
it's even harder to go public james
simpson of middletown new york
did as a long-term republican i can't
possibly in good conscience support
this type of president this republican
party is not
my republican party simpson's video is
one of close to a thousand
submitted to a group called republican
voters against trump
this is insane the group's posting
videos of republicans
not supporting the president and they're
often blunt
reasons he's just not stupid in me he's
cruel they're bringing crime they're
rapists
it's time to reclaim the republican
party from donald trump
now the group isn't trying to turn a big
portion of hardcore trump supporters it
wants to peel away some who might have
reservations
showing them that there's other people
like them conor metz works on videos for
the group
he says the strategy is to give
republicans a sort of permission to vote
democrat to show them it's okay
whether they're voting for the first
time or the 20th my family was very
republican and here i am 97
watching someone like
trump now the group focuses on swing
states places where
even if it only convinces a small
fraction of voters to cross
it can make a difference the road to the
white house gets very complicated for
donald trump
without states like wisconsin where he
won by less than one percent
republicans like us voting for joe biden
could turn this um
from a narrow trump win to a biden
landslide
have you lost friends you know um there
are individuals that
i wouldn't say that i've lost friends
okay
i would say that for myself i've lost
respect
for some of my friends it's still sad it
is sad it is a sad thing yeah
joe biden loves our country the group
was founded by established long
republican strategists commentators and
staffers
they say the goal isn't to tear the
party down just to remove
trump and rebuild i've never voted for a
democrat
the idea is to go back mike armstrong
global news
middletown new york and that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is
muscadab at harbor in nova scotia
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you